and india isn't just importing vaccines
from abroad it has
stopped exporting its own production of
them as well
and that threatens to have a serious
knock-on effect for other countries
still waiting to immunize their own
populations
india is a powerhouse behind kovacs the
international program
coordinating vaccines to the world's
poorest nations about
half of kovac's doses are on order from
india's serum institute
through kovacs and bilateral deals many
countries
are depending on india that includes
nations in africa
and in asia places including afghanistan
myanmar
and bangladesh let's take a closer
look now at bangladesh now daca is
relying on india to pull
through and deliver doses until then
health officials have put the country on
lockdown
and while infections have started
dropping the government has decided to
extend the measures for now
but that is turning out to be terribly
tough for the poorest people in the
country
[Applause]
there are many new mouths to feed in the
bangladeshi capital dakar
the coronavirus pandemic and the
lockdown are hitting people hard
especially those already straining to
make ends meet
for many the food provided by this
charity is all they have to eat
at the end of their daily ramadan fast
or iftar
[Music]
i've lost my job in this coronavirus
pandemic i have no earnings
so i come here for iftar
i am fasting i pull my rickshaw under
the sun
but i make very little money and i'm too
poor to buy iftar
so i come here for free food
the government imposed a strict
nationwide lockdown in april
to try to contain a massive surge in
infections
they're optimistic that the measures are
working as cases appear to be falling
but the restrictions are taking a heavy
toll more than two-thirds of people in
bangladesh have been forced to stop work
or close their businesses at least for a
time because of the pandemic
these lockdowns are hitting our bread
and butter i stopped dates for ramadan
but because of the lockdown i had to
keep my shop closed
the dates are rotting as i was unable to
sell them
this is difficult for us these lockdowns
my perfumes and skull caps are still
inside my closed shop
i was expecting to sell them all during
the month over ramadan
before eid but i doubt that's going to
happen it is very problematic for us
but the government is resisting pressure
to open up more quickly
saying this would lead to more
casualties especially with the end of
ramadan approaching
in the middle of may they're also
concerned that what's happening in india
could come to bangladesh
they say if the indian variant is
allowed to circulate on the streets of
bangladesh
the consequences would be devastating
they're urging bangladeshis not to let
their guard down despite their desire to
get back to normal
for many though this situation is
already dire
and will only get worse if the pandemic
is not brought
under control
joining us is sham hussein who leads the
public health association of bangladesh
and has been working
on public health matters for several
decades
i'm curious because we've seen this play
out
across the world the poor are
disproportionately
impacted by the pandemic what is the
government of bangladesh doing about
that
thank you very much actually the
poor in bangladesh in compared to the
statistics is suffering less than the
little
higher group but still the
big question is there isn't there is an
economic crisis
about the poor so particularly during
the lockdown
so bangladesh government is providing
financial support
to these people who are really is not
earning in every day earning income
that's one support is given by the
bengal government there are a number of
philanthropic organizations
as well as individuals are also coming
up to support this group
to increase the economic situations of
this
poor those who are not working
who are working on a daily basis and
some of them
already lose their job so this is the
important interventions provided by the
government and as a public health expert
you know that
the economic situation always goes hand
in hand now you've been tracking the
pandemic from the beginning
and one thing i'm curious about is are
you worried about a surge
after ramadan ends later this month
actually the second surge has created a
lot of problem
the the the that has increases
30 percent's positivity rate and
after the second week of march
but fortunately they it has come
down and positivity rate is not going
slow now it is 8.97
positivity rate but uh
the during the ramadan and
there are i mean you know we have a
religious festival the eat festivals
there are a lot of moment of the people
from one
place to one place there will be a lot
of movement in the market
that will create a new search may
yet may create a new search after the
year
government is very much aware of these
situations so
as in public experts we are providing
these technical suggestions to the
government
and how this can really help this
mitigate this act this
the future uh third
uh wave uh
third wave because we are already uh
past the second wave
because in bangladesh the first day was
in
2000 in march 2020 the first case was
detected on
8th march 2020 and and
and there was quite reductions in in
and in detections right by
a year time so in february it was only
a three to four percent so it's
definitely something
so it's definitely something to watch i
want to quickly ask you how concerned
you are
about this covet variant circulating in
india just next door
and so for today's informations
in bangladesh we could not actually
identify the
indian varieties in our laboratory so
far
so far but the the ied cr is our one of
the
institutions who are working with these
trends and they have given a press
release today there is no
indian variance in bangladesh but of
course
uh indian very variance uh there is
every possibilities of coming to indian
variance from bangladesh because we have
a common border
but partners government has closed the
border for last
couple of last two then continue with
till
two weeks and that will give us the
opportunity
to decrease this uh this indian
variant to try and migrate it in
bangladesh to monitor this situation
because you do have
a long border chamonix hussein thank you
so much for joining us
welcome thank you as we've been
mentioning a new double mutation of the
coronavirus has been partly blamed for
the rapid increase in cases in
india and it's something that makes
neighboring states such as bangladesh
particularly vulnerable
experts say it is more infectious and
deadly than earlier variants
here's what we know the west indian
state of maharashtra
is where the b1617 variant of the
coronavirus was first recorded
in december 2020
the strain has two mutations on its
spike protein
that's the bit of the virus that gets it
into our body's cells
both genetic mutations have cropped up
before around the world in other strains
of the coronavirus
and when they did they were linked to
the virus passing between
people more easily they were also linked
to the virus being better able to get
past the body's defenses
we've seen a systematic increase in
cases across india
more or less taking off at the same time
suggesting that what might be happening
is that something that is more
transmissible between people
is very rapidly moving through the
population of people who are yet to
contract the infection
and therefore spreading faster but how
quickly does this new type spread
to get a handle on that researchers need
to be able to see when people have it
and when they die from it which means
sequencing the viruses genes
that research has been extremely limited
so far in india
out of millions of cases in this new
wave only around a thousand sequences
have been published
meanwhile scientists across the world
are working to find out how
deadly b161 is as the number of people
dying continues to rise
their answers can't come quickly enough
you